anyway here with reaction the author of
the upcoming book
uh for such a time as this
my faith journey through the white house
and beyond outnumbered co-host kelly
mcinanny
and fox news contributor ari fleischer
ari we start with you
your take um it seems to me that there's
a lot of projection in this world
what a memory lane you just walked down
a
poison injected into the american body
politic
by cnn look sean you cleverly humorously
called joe biden
a sippy cup president what did cnn do
to the nation by telling everybody all
the time
that the 2016 election was
illegitimately won by donald trump
because he colluded with russia
influenced the results of the election
and then all the pylons for four
straight years
basically questioning the president's
legitimacy and as you point out the
hitler the mussolini all the other
references to fascism and then cnn says
it's the other guy
i mean it just can't work that way so
good for you sean you blew a whistle and
i guess cnn doesn't want to hear it
they don't want to hear it and you know
the difference too kaley and
congratulations on your book i'm looking
forward to reading it when it comes out
um but i'd like to say and i say this
often yes i'm a member of the press
i am a talk show host well what is the
talk show host
i can produce thousands of hours of
straight news coverage on radio and tv
thousands of hours of investigative
reporting that we do
that others do not we talk about culture
we talk about sports
and yes i give my opinion and i don't
hide the fact that i
am a a loud proud unapologetic
unapologetic conservative i'm like a
whole newspaper they say they're
journalists
they're not journalists that's a lie
yeah you've done more journalism than
any
one of them i mean i watched you through
the trump years unravel the russia
collusion conspiracy theory
layer by layer week by week and
meanwhile i got to tell you sean i'm a
little worried for you i got a little
fatal attraction vibe as i was watching
those clips
uh for brian stelter you know his he
does not have reliable sources but he
does reliably stalk
you uh you remember he asked jim saki
you know what's the press getting wrong
he's fawning coverage of joe biden fun
and coverage
of gensake crazy and then he broadcasts
in his boxers and
you know it appears many cnn hosts have
a proclivity uh
broadcasting half clothed both him and
then of course jeffrey tube and they've
got a lot of issues no wonder the
decline in viewership
yeah why'd you have to bring up jeff
toobin that brings up very bad memories
for anybody that has a
soul and a conscience you know the the
thing that i find most interesting
yeah and i was quoted last week
somewhere saying that i just don't care
what other people say
ari whatever whatever switch i'm
supposed to have that cares about what
other people think of me
it doesn't exist they seem to be so
hypersensitive
in their in their little blue check
bubble world that they live in
that they can't take the criticism
that they rightly deserve nor admit that
they are biased
and you know i used to be a cnn
contributor i spent two years there and
i've got to say it was under a different
president
it was not under uh their current
president
it was a very different news gathering
organization and right now
the direction flows from the top and
basically the top is to play to the left
play to the far
left use the words that divide the
country and go after fox
i'm writing a book about the media it's
called broken cnn is going to have its
own chapter in it
and i'll tell you a couple things sean
cnn put michael avenatti on the air
250 times
in the space of less than one year
michael avenatti became the cnn go-to
person that tells you how wrong their
judgment is
going into this now brian stetler talked
about poison and bad words
brianna keeler two weeks ago one of
their anchors called senator rand paul
of kentucky
an ass on the air i don't remember brian
stetler telling her she shouldn't have
talked like that that that's wrong
and then brian in his monologue accused
you of
playing in violence encouraging people
toward violence
what about chris cuomo who at the height
of the george floyd protests
when cities were under curfew across
america said i don't remember seeing
anywhere that protests were supposed to
be
peaceful where was brian stella's
criticism of chris cuomo
so both you have great books coming out
we look forward to it all right thank
you kaylee thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else